老公只要愿意出钱，
你就得感谢他，
你就得说你看他有那么多的有特殊儿童的家庭啊，
老公，
我觉得你真的是算是男人当中有良心的，
有责任心的，
你真的做的已经很好了，
就得这么说话，
否则的话，
如果你对他的期待，
期待他像你一样对孩子那么上心，
对孩子那么负责任的话，
你们两个人之间一定会出现矛盾，
他一定会逃避，
他到最后的话，
他逃避，
他没有太多的损失，
他没有太多的风险，
她直接把你们娘儿俩踹出去，
她就可以重新生活，
但是你不可以，
你只能绑她过。
我是个特殊宝妈，
因为我们家现在还好吧，
两年前我就发现她情绪这块也不对劲，
以前的时候是很好的，
因为我们家小孩子早产，
并检查出来自基因突变，
我们是从小孩11月月开始啊，
就开始干预了，
干预这一块是我负责的，
他就负责赚钱。
两年前我就发现他发过两次大脾气吧，
早把啊凳子啊那些弄烂了，
发脾气，
后面经过我们两个沟通都还可以，
我觉得感情这一块嘛，
好像是换了一个新的一样子，
那他心已经不在对方身上了，
现在这两年后生活条件是比以前要好一点吧，
那工作上面也是不错，
也有1万多一个月，
主要是担心小孩这一块是我在做，
我比较累，
他也不体谅我，
不理解我。
他也配合干预小孩，
每天都是晚上9点多10点才回来，
他工作也比较忙，
我现在思考的是一些问题，
我现在没有办法工作，
我今年30岁，
我刚预小孩也很累，
身体没以前那么好，
他们家又是一个男孩子，
我女儿这样，
我们基因的问题，
我问她要不要生二胎，
他又说不想生，
现在没有王位，
自常我又担心，
我说如果男天你小了，
我又老了，
我现在为在社会上我又工作不了嘛，
我这样拖下去对我没有任何好处嘛，
不确定这种状况，
你俩都是头婚呢，
还是重组家庭，
我们两个是头婚，
他对婚姻也是比较重视的，
我担心她哪一天万一她想生小孩了，
我问他，
他说找别人生，
他这一句话，
这让我心里就很不安的。
还有一点就是我是远嫁的，
我是广东的，
他是湖北的，
父母两边都是帮不了忙的，
都是靠自己的，
我们生活在东莞，
现在他给我花钱，
生活费也有1万，
主要也是花给小孩的，
也很省，
他现在给我这么多钱，
灵活自用，
是信用卡里面的，
因为我看他工作方面，
他未来肯定是，
就是说上升空间是越来越高了嘛，
我带小孩我就出去，
如果哪一天我们掰了怎么办？
其实你像你应该怎么给我留一条后路，
是这样啊，
如果现在。
双方父母都帮不上忙，
那我现在就调整我的心态和策略，
我的心态和策略就是我老公还愿意给我钱的时候，
趁我老公还愿意养这个孩子的时候，
我就多要点钱，
他既然一个月愿意给1万，
那你过段时间你就说孩子又报了什么班了，
这个学费又多贵了一万二，
能不能行，
实际上我花在孩子身上的话，
花不了那么多钱，
那我每个月能攒个1万块钱，
每个月攒这1万块钱的话，
我就默默的攒着，
攒着攒着，
以防万一，
万一他有一天他不想负担了呢，
不想跟我过了呢，
钱某种程度上也是我和孩子的保命钱。
再有一个就对他不要有太多的期待，
不要期待他像你一样去关心孩子的进度，
关心孩子的康复啊什么的，
他去年给了我有10万吧，
他是说给我灵活利用，
他就跟我讲，
我叫他给我现金生活，
我就没有花那10万，
我就花现金，
对，
就花现用信用卡啊，
我就担心，
因为我们现在身体会是什么样的问题啊，
就万一哪一天他再找我去做试管，
我就担心我身体不是很好，
如果做个试管会不会有癌变，
那些其他原因会影响我的身体，
所以我也不敢再生了，
咱们以后走一步再看一步，
看看孩子康复的状态，
看看两口子的感情状态，
看看你老公的责任心和良心的额度。
都再定现在这个状态，
你就按我的方法做，
多存钱，
为你和孩子存点余粮，
存点保命钱。
第二，
你一定要放弃期待哦，
你只有放弃期待了，
你们两口子日子才有可能四平八稳的往下过。
放弃什么期待，
就是我刚刚讲的那3句话，
不要期待你老公跟你一样爱孩子，
不要期待你老公对孩子跟你一样的负责任和上心，
你老公只要愿意出钱，
你就得感谢他，
你就得说啊，
你看看有那么多的有特殊儿童的家庭啊，
老公，
我觉得你真的是算是男人当中有良心的，
有责任心的，
你真的做的已经很好了，
就得这么说话，
否则的话，
如果你对他的期待，
期待他像你一样对孩子那么上心，
对孩子那么负责任的话，
你们两个人之间一定会出现矛盾，
他一定会逃避，
到最后的话，
他逃避，
他没有太多的损失，
他没有太多的风险，
他直接把你们娘儿俩踹出去，
他就可以重新生活，
但是你不可以，
你只能绑着他过，
既然我只能绑着你过的话，
我就得想，
我怎么才能笼络住你的心，
我怎么才能给你树立一个好父亲的形象，
我怎么才能给你树立一个在亲戚朋友面前的对家庭对孩子负责任的形象，
我怎么才能把你嫁在一个好人的位置上，
让你永远不能甩掉我和孩子，
他现在对小孩放心度啊，
这个期待我也没有，
因为我一直关注你嘛，
我也没有给他放太多的期待，
因为我们家里就一家三口。
他下班时候陪小孩玩一下，
互动一下，
因为小孩我的想法是我想让他上普校，
他是想法是到那个特殊学校里面，
因为我们小孩现在40岁半嘛，
以前很严重的，
我带他干预，
现在已经是说会基本交流了，
只是能力差一点，
其他各方面都是跟别的小朋友比，
可能别的小朋友四岁，
他可能是两岁多的智商，
这样子你没有听明白，
刚才我要表达的意思是什么，
我要表达的意思是一方面不要给这个男人太多的负面情绪，
不要给他任何的压力，
另一方面要在亲人朋友，
社会关系里面塑造一个好爸爸，
有责任心，
有爱心，
有担当的，
不抛弃这个生病的孩子的这样一个形象，
一定要把她嫁在那儿，
明白吗？
到哪了，
亲戚朋友都夸他一顿，
觉得他有责任心，
觉得他有善良的心，
这方面他还是有的，
因为我们小朋友啊，
他从出生的那个也花了也有100来万了，
这方面他还好，
但是哪一天可能就是不管我了，
但现在也没办法上班，
因为我想孩试过去做一个手工，
真的太累了，
坚持不下，
要带小孩干预，
其实你还有一个业务方向，
你多学一点啊，
这个事儿不一定能干成，
不一定能做起来，
你多记录一下孩子康复的过程，
多分享一下孩子康复你学到的知识，
多分享一下你的孩子是怎么一步一步康复过来。
来的，
这个或许对于你来说是另外一个生财之道，
我话只能点到这儿，
你一定要去记录，
用心去记录，
这些知识也是非常值得分享的知识，
经验，
也是非常值得分享的经验，
孩子怎么一点一点变好的，
这个变好的过程你到底用了哪些东西啊，
他未必而能做起来，
但是这个过程对于你来说的话也很治愈，
我也想过做这评啊，
做这方面他老公他不同意做，
做小孩这直接不想记录的太详细，
发到抖音上面，
他想法这样子的，
因为我也想过做抖音跟为每个小孩的也不一样嘛，
也可以给别人这样子看一下啊，
他是怎么干预过来的，
他不太同意，
这方面你先做呀，
如果你做了能挣钱了，
他还不同意吗？
你偷偷做，
你给他拉黑呀，
抖音里面有一个功能，
就是拉黑所有你认识的人，
小来如果再过两年，
他如果上了特效的话，
像我这样子，
因为我也不知道我做什么事比较好，
因为我一这几年一直是弄小孩在学这方面的相关知识，
其实你可以去应聘一下特殊学校里面的老师，
护理啊什么的，
因为你自己的孩子是应理，
如果说有这种特殊的学校，
特殊的康复机构，
特殊的培训机构，
我正好把我学到的东西学以致用，
我还能帮助到别人，
这也是我的价值，
这也是一个就业方向，
培诊师啊，
是吧，
培训啊，
特殊孩子的康复啊，
因为你自己。
确实也一路陪着自己的孩子，
久病成医，
确实是一个经验啊，
谢谢啊，
好拜拜啊，
嗯，
刚刚我看到有个朋友说，
姐真的是在认真的给建议，
因为我们人要他一定要找到一点生命当中有一个牵引，
有一个抓手，
他这日子才能熬得下去，
不然的话，
他天天带着一个特殊的孩子啊，
镇定的孩子，
他这个心气儿就被磨光了，
一定要对未来一定要有一个憧憬，
有一个抓手，
如果我正好在陪伴我自己的特殊孩子的过程当中，
我积累了经验，
积累了这些知识，
我将来又能用这些经验和知识混口饭吃啊，
又能帮助别人，
他就是一个生命的意义，
生命的意义就可以让他能够承托住，
万一有一天说这老公不要我了，
万一有一天那我自己能承托得住，
是不是每天都去记录我学到了什么知识，
我有了什么经验？
孩子有了什么好转？
孩子在什么干预下？
他为什么好转？
原因是什么？
逻辑是什么？
每天都去记录这些，
怎么拉黑所有认识的人，
直接在抖音上搜，
如果我做抖音，
我怎么屏蔽所有认识的人，
一定会有博主教你的啊，
学知识就要主动，
要积极，
不是说谁给你喂饭喂到嘴里来了，
不是的，
在这个社会上混口饭吃，
是要我自己去刨食儿的，
是要我自己到处去刨食儿的，
记得点赞。
FA.